Nous avons l'honneur de vous annoncer la présence en 3e
position sur notre liste du général Christophe Gomar.
Il a servi la France au plus haut niveau,
il a porté euh. Les armes de la France sur euh.
Beaucoup de théâtres d'opérations extérieures.
Voilà ce que je voulais souligner en en réexprimant ma
gratitude, ma reconnaissance,
ma fierté de pouvoir compter sur l'engagement euh.
Du général Christophe Gomar.
Je me réjouis de me présenter à vous aujourd'hui,
et non pas comme
ancien directeur du renseignement militaire,
mais bien comme candidat
aux élections européens
sur la liste de François Xavier Bellami
et donc sur la liste des républicains.